apple's iphone event just happened
yesterday and they finally unveiled
their iphone 12 lineup so in this video
i'm gonna wrap up all of the new
features into just a few minutes
while comparing them to the previous
iphone 11
with the goal of helping you decide if
it's worth upgrading to the iphone 12
if you already have the iphone 11 the
10r
the 8 the 7 the 6 or any other iphone
now before we get started i want to
mention that i already created a video
specifically for the iphone 12 pro
models
so if you're interested in that be sure
to watch that video after this one is
over
first things first the iphone 12 gets
the brand new design
with flat aluminum edges on the sides
which i think looks
incredibly clean just like we got on the
modern ipad pro
but what makes it even better is that
the thickness of the iphone 12 went down
to 7.4 millimeters
compared to 8.3 on the iphone 11 so it's
gonna feel
super nice especially since it's now 16
percent lighter
164 grams compared to 194 grams on the
11.
and because of the flat sides the glass
on the front is no longer
curved which allowed apple to make the
bezels thinner
while keeping the same 6.1 inch display
size
which leads to a 15 smaller and more
compact phone
and by the way the thinner bezels make
the notch look smaller
while it physically isn't so keep that
in mind now i do want to mention that
for the first time ever
there's also the new iphone 12 mini
which comes with a 5.4 inch display
making it much smaller and lighter being
a great choice for kids
or people with smaller hands but keep in
mind that the battery life
isn't going to be as good but other than
the size the mini is
literally identical to the regular 12 in
terms of the features and the specs
so everything that i'm gonna say about
the iphone 12 for the rest of this video
also applies to the mini except for the
unfortunate fact
that the mini is not going to be
shipping until next month
starting at 699 another interesting
difference is that the camera bump
on the back is actually larger compared
to the one on the iphone 11
and as far as the color options for the
iphone 12 yellow is going away
while there is a new shade of green and
a new blue color
to replace the purple on the iphone 11
and while they still have product red
it looks quite a bit lighter than the
iphone 11 version
now perhaps the most shocking feature is
the display the iphone 12 now gets the
same
exact super retina xdr oled display
as the pro models which is a massive
upgrade
from the iphone 11 which used an lcd
display
this means the iphone 12 gets 1200 nits
of peak brightness while viewing hdr
content
it gets much more contrast much better
colors
and a huge boost in pixels per inch
at 460 just like the pro model
the only downside is that the iphone 12
maxes out at 625 nits in typical use
compared to 800 nits on the iphone 12
pro models
apple has now upgraded the front glass
using a new ceramic substrate technology
giving it four times better drop
protection according to apple
and a huge upgrade is water resistance
ip68 at 6 meters for up to 30 minutes
compared to only 2 meters
on the iphone 11. now a pretty huge new
feature that apple focused a lot on
during the event
is 5g support but we totally
weren't expecting the regular iphone 12
to also support millimeter wave 5g
specifically for us customers
so compared to the iphone 11 you're
getting sub 65g
millimeter wave 5g and faster regular
lte speeds
up to 2 gigabits per second with 4x4
mimo
compared to 1 gigabit per second with
2x2 mimo on the iphone 11.
apple also released the new smart data
mode which automatically switches to lte
when you don't need 5g speed so that
helps keep the rated battery life the
same as the iphone 11
which is very surprising considering the
fact that the 12 got smaller
and thinner the iphone 12 also gets the
new super efficient
5 nanometer a14 bionic chip which is
quite a bit faster
in basically every single way so if you
want to see the full comparison with
benchmarks and performance differences
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out now before i get into the camera
differences
i want to touch on a feature that i'm
really excited for
magsafe apple has basically built
magnets into the wireless charging coil
inside of the iphone itself so the brand
new
super compact magsafe wireless charger
magnetically snaps onto the back of the
iphone
so you can actually use it while it's
wirelessly charging
at a much faster 15 watts compared to
7.5 watts
using qi chargers like the iphone 11 is
limited to
but what makes it even more special is
the new mac safe accessories
like the wallet which can hold onto the
back of a naked iphone 12
with nothing but the built-in magnets
there's also a lineup of new cases
which have magnets built into the case
itself as well so they're easier to put
on and
take off and you can even add the wallet
on top of the case
thanks to the magnets apple also has a
couple of extra magsafe accessories
coming in the future
like the magsafe duo charger a magnetic
car mount and a multi-charging dock from
belkin
and apple has already confirmed that
third-party companies are beginning
to make accessories like pop socket
which will use the magnets in creative
ways
now i personally think that this is
going to be a bigger deal
than most people are making it out to be
and we just have to wait and see what
accessory makers
will come up with in the near future now
let's finally get
into the cameras and while you might not
think there's that big of a difference
since we get the same three cameras as
before there actually
are some interesting upgrades first off
i want to mention that the a14 chip's
extra performance
impacts every camera feature especially
the neural engine
which is now twice as fast and it also
comes with a new image signal processor
as well
so keep that in mind the hardware on the
ultrawide camera
is basically unchanged but the wide
camera is getting some new upgrades
first off it has a faster f 1.6 aperture
compared to f 1.8 on the 11
so it lets in more light and it gets a
new seven element lens
compared to the old one with six
elements so these changes help the
iphone 12's
wide camera get 27 percent better low
light performance
not only that but apple mentioned that
the optical image stabilization is now
up to five times faster than before
so your video footage should be more
stable and your photos will turn out
sharp
more often than before what's really
exciting is that we now finally have
night mode on all of the cameras
including
the selfie camera while the iphone 11
only gets it on the main one
and it's the exact same story for
apple's deep fusion feature
and we'll be testing out exactly how
much better those deep fusion selfies
are going to look
compared to the iphone 11 so if you're
not already subscribed
do so right now and by the way thank you
guys for helping us
finally reach 400 000 subscribers so
let's go for 500k
the iphone 12 also gets the third
generation of smart hdr
with scene detection so you're not only
getting improved dynamic range
but it now looks at and adjusts various
parts of the scene
instead of just your face in the
background like it did on the iphone 11
in terms of video recording we now get a
new night mode
time lapse feature and you can now
record in the new
dolby vision hdr mode at up to 30 frames
per second
compared to 60 fps on the pro models but
we're not really sure how big of a deal
this will be for most people
alright so there you guys go those are
all the changes and new features
compared to last year's iphone 11
so now let's get into if it's actually
worth upgrading
first off if you have the iphone 10r or
older
like the iphone 6 7 or the 8
then i would 100 recommend upgrading
because the value of the iphone 12 is
just insane for
the price and the camera quality is so
much better than even the iphone 10r
and people who love smaller iphones can
now get the mini
which gets identical features and specs
as the iphone 12.
but by far the most difficult upgrade
decision
is if you already have the iphone 11 so
let's get into the features that will
actually matter
in the real world while you might not
care about 5g
it could actually make a huge difference
in day-to-day use
the best 4g lte speed we've ever got on
the iphone 11 pro max
using t-mobile has been around 59
megabits per second
even with full bars and very recently
speed tests have been released showing
mid band 5g on t-mobile's network
using the iphone 12 reaching speeds of
up to 621 megabits per second
and that's not even sub 65g on top of
that
i do want to remind you that regular lte
is getting twice as fast compared to the
iphone 11
so there's a very good chance that the
iphone 12 will greatly
improve cellular service across the
board
making it much better for people who are
having issues right now
another huge reason to upgrade from the
iphone 11 to the 12
is of course the new design which is
most likely going to stay
this way for the next few years and i
think the new max save feature is going
to be a huge hit
once more accessories become available
by far
the biggest change is in the displays
you're going from an lcd panel
with low resolution to quite literally
the same oled panel that you get on the
iphone 12 pro
so display quality is getting a huge
upgrade of course
you've now got the new a14 chip and
we're gonna have to see how fast that
really is
and the cameras should be a good
improvement across the board
especially since you can now take night
mode shots with any of the cameras
the only real downside this year is that
you don't get a charger
or earpods in the box and since the
iphone 12 now comes with the usbc
to lightning cable people with older 5
watt charging bricks
will either have to buy a new one from
apple or buy a wireless charger
thankfully anker's new 20 watt fast
charger is currently on sale for 16
on amazon if you use the coupon so it's
perfect for the iphone 12
and i'm gonna leave links down in the
description below to that sale
but here is my final piece of advice on
if you should upgrade to the iphone 12.
in my opinion there is a much bigger
difference
going from the iphone 11 to the 12
compared to last year
when we went from the 10r to the 11. and
frankly
i'm shocked at how much value apple
packed into the 12
compared to the pro which only gets a
couple of extra features
like the telephoto lens so in my opinion
the 6.1 inch iphone 12 is the star of
the show
and i think a ton of people are going to
be upgrading from older iphones
if this video was helpful go ahead and
tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
for our hands-on full comparison videos
like our unbiased camera comparison and
if you're thinking about upgrading to
the iphone 12
pro models check out that video right
over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one